the orders of everybody is procedural
matter with you here with another
Borderlands the pre-sequel video today
we're going to be looking at a sonic
easter egg within the pre-sequel so if
you head over this Randy's waist and you
go to the near around the bottom of the
map where the two exits to regular range
are you saw on the map in the game I
pointed you to it you're gonna run over
there you're gonna hop up on these rocks
into this little lava crater area and
you're gonna hopefully find the fubu
phonic cragun which is a reference to
sonic the hedgehog from sega now he is
all golden and you might think whoa
perceive the Sonics blue however if you
know a little bit of Sonic lore then you
know when he when he noms on one of his
Chaos Emeralds he goes super soft mode
and he turns golden and that's what we
have here we have food profiling or if
you do do this in normal I'm in true
vault hunter mode if you do this normal
you will find him to be just the phonic
Ragan and he'll be more closer to blue
than golden so he does his spin attack
where he spins up in a ball and charge
that you have little electricity damage
however he is like a normal cracking
he's resistant resistant to fire and
electricity does normal good damage on
him so it's kind of weird he will drop
money or rings every time you hit him
just like the sonic does in his sonic
games and when you kill him he explodes
in a giant circle of rings and money way
just like Sonic so it is a cut pretty
cool Easter Egg it's kind of funny he's
not there he's not very tough at all my
opinion I kind of mess around with him
just to show a little bit of what he's
like and there is actually a challenge
in in Game to kill the phonic cragun
which I'm assuming the food / fauna
cragun would work too so it's kind of
it's pretty cool I I've tried farming
him a few times a note he will not
always a spawn here like he will not
always spawn this is the only spot I've
ever seen him spawn it but he doesn't
spawn here every time so if you want to
for him for a legendary that I don't
know if he drops one
then head over to the exit of regolith
range right there head back and then you
save them quit you all always spawn from
that exit and you can do it so you see
there's also chest there for some good
Lutz and yeah so I try farming for a
little bit and it didn't work out I
never got anything but if you guys want
to try farming him then go for it so
it's basically gonna be it for this
video I if you jump behind either the
waterfalls you'll fall out of the map
since there's no grab behind them just
like cute cool little thing this I'm
just falling footage will play for the
rest of the video and I hope you guys
have enjoyed this quick little guide on
how to get to the Fupa phonic easter egg
the supersonic easter egg the sonic at
the Hedgehog easter egg I do hope you
guys like my borderlines content if you
do make sure you check out more of my
channel um hit up more my videos since I
do do a lot of legendary God so if you
want to find out how to do some
legendaries get some legendaries and how
good they are then check that out maybe
I'll try farming this guy more for some
uh some good old legendary since he has
a unique name so I'm assuming he's gonna
be dropping a unique legendary but I
don't know we'll find out so hope you
guys have enjoyed and yet about it I'll
see you later peace out